this video sponsored by idol heroes
click the link in the description to
download the game for free hey guys
JK Rowling here to make a little
clarification on something that's of
monumental importance to the world of
Harry Potter
yes Quidditch players can get CTE in
fact there are a lot of squibs out there
who weren't born non-magical but lost
their abilities after repeated blows to
the head by bludgers and why hasn't
Hermione raised the alarm about this
along with how self-liberation
well she's getting kickbacks from the
Quidditch Association who want to make
sure those fat advertising checks from
Bertie Botts every flavour beans keep on
coming but can't magic cure CTE you
might ask
after all it fixed Harry's broken skull
well it could but Madame Pomfrey is in
bed with big potion who wants you to be
hooked on their brain be good elixir
alright you may have figured out by now
that a I'm not actually JK Rowling and B
this video is in regards to her various
tweaks to Harry Potter Canon what
started as a clarification on
Dumbledore's personal life mere months
after the series concluded slowly
evolved into an avalanche of unnecessary
Canon additions to the Harry Potter
universe that Avalanche recently gave us
the qualification on the specific
intensity of Dumbledore's romantic life
but nothing will ever top the revelation
that Wizards historically speaking used
to poo themselves so we had to ask why
why is this happening
her fans craving more detail about
fictional worlds were invested in is
simple and incredibly relatable we love
these worlds and we want to know more we
start with a question like where did
snow come from or was cobb still
dreaming
then we move on to big questions like
these toads mushroom a hat or part of
his head those questions begin more
questions until we find ourselves asking
the real questions like if wizards
rejected muggle technology why are there
toilets and Hogwarts and that's why
we're here today
of course JK Rowling isn't the only
huckster of canon as Mike Rugnetta notes
and his incredible essay Canon is an
abyss these occurrences are everywhere
Nintendo has confirmed that toads head
is not a hat and a designer from
Dungeons and Dragons has canonically
declared that gnome but smell like
honeysuckle and bromine more recently
Kevin Feige has canonically clarified
why Nick Fury didn't call Captain Marvel
during several near extinction scenarios
while Rugnetta has argued that cannon is
a bottomless abyss of which there is no
end and he's not wrong I think there's
another way to understand our canonical
obsession and it's not just about how we
interact with the fictional worlds we
love but how we interact with our own
world welcome to this wisecrack edition
on Canon and spoilers ahead for Harry
Potter but before we jump into that I
want to give a shout out to our sponsors
over at Idol heroes I spend most of my
days thinking critically about books
movies TV shows and general culture
stuff so the thing that really allows me
to unwind is video games idol heroes
reached out to see if we dig their games
so I downloaded it and it's an awesome
hero collector game best part is the
game has a really great sense of humor
the hero designs are colorful hilarious
and the animations are really dynamic
you can play anytime anywhere there are
six factions in the game more than 300
unique heroes daily tasks you can
complete in just 5 minutes and log
request to all you need to bring to the
battle is strategy so if you want to
give it a try for yourself check it out
now by clicking the link in the
description to download Idol heroes for
free and now back to the show in terms
of cannon we are living in a very
specific historical moment now first of
all Shakespeare didn't have Twitter but
more importantly he wasn't living in an
era of engagement brands don't just make
extra canonical content due to our
voracious demand they do it in the name
of one of the most important marketing
metrics engagement engagements is in the
world of brand building simply any level
of interactive
with a brand beyond spectatorship that
means likes shares forum posts fan
theories it's all engagement today the
number of eyeballs on your brand isn't
enough social media marketers and
youtubers know the real way to spread
brand recall is to have consumers
interact with your brand hence the birth
of alternate reality games to promote
shows clever subway ads that make you do
puzzles or the rise of comments and view
time as meaningful measurements of
success in the world of content
production cannon is engagement and
engagement is money JK Rowling may not
be explicitly out to make a buck by
manufacturing more and more Canon but
the study of Canon the discussion of
cannon and the consuming of cannon all
create meaningful engagement for the
Harry Potter brand whether it's a
Gryffindor scarf a custom lightsaber or
a collectible pickle Rick engagement
moves inventory and this logic has taken
over everything this kind of cannon
production may have existed in games
like war hammer or Dungeons & Dragons
back in the day but it's slowly
overtaking the mainstream today's games
like overwatch or apex legends have
whole character biographies an
additional cannon to consume along with
them these games are by their very
format plot lists but plotless games
don't make for good meaningful emotional
engagement and meaningful emotional
engagement means buku bucks but I don't
want to pin this on meeting companies
emotionally exploiting our need to be
absorbed in a highly monetized fantasy
world after all JK Rowling has more than
enough money but if we go back to even
before stock markets we can see how
canonical meddling was less about making
money and more about anxiety over one's
place in the world like Rowling authors
have long been clarifying their works
even Cicero as the classics professor
Caroline Bishop notes meticulously
commented on his old texts and speeches
clarifying how his original works should
really be read this meddling inspired
others Virgil Horace and propitious to
give the reader a helping hand and
interpreting their own words bishop
notes that JK Rowling finds herself in
the company of navikev who wrote his own
ed notes for ADA under a pseudonym and
TS Eliot who provided his own notes to
his famous work the wasteland in many
cases clarifying canon spoke to enough
thoroughly
xiety Cicero bishop writes wanted to
cement his legacy and because he was a
politician win more votes there were few
things more important than legacy to
these giants of intellect and
continually revising their work was
their way of trying to ensure their
image lived on unlike rolling TS Eliot
Nabokov Cicero or Virgil didn't have
Twitter and thus didn't have hordes of
fans asking just how intense was Humbert
Humberts romantic life thank God now on
the one hand I really don't want to know
but on the other the ease of which canon
can be tweaked now with a tweet or a
television appearance means authors are
even more prone to impulsivity and as
well argue the resulting of this of
canon isn't just annoying it can make
our lives deeply nihilistic now to find
out just what the hell we're talking
about we're gonna get real metaphysical
with 20th century philosopher Martin
Heidegger pedigrees primary focus was
our existence in the world he argued
that since the ancient Greeks
philosophers and literally everyone else
deeply misunderstood the question of
being so much so that he had to invent a
bunch of words just to explain it now
this all gets really jargony and hard to
follow but most simply he is less
interested in being than what he calls
da sign which translates to being there
in other words humans don't exist as
some isolated entity apart from
everything else we exist in a world so
to understand our existence we have to
understand our relationship to the
environment around us as such instead of
simply being his writing is full of
being with being in and being towards
which brings us to being in the world
the idea that our existence is fully
immersed in the reality around us for
Heidegger we are thrown into the world
and this thoroughness which is his term
is a key component of our being as
philosopher Simon Critchley summarises
thoroughness is the simple awareness
that we always find ourselves somewhere
namely delivered over to a world with
which we are fascinated a world we share
with others there's something about the
fictional worlds we get lost in that
speaks to this basic question of being
when we read Harry Potter we lose
ourselves in the narrative of a boy
destined to be a great
and we are metaphorically speaking
thrown into this fictional universe and
along with other fans are enthralled and
curious about the laws of magic the
history of Hogwarts and so on for
Heidegger being in the world is about
the world disclosing itself to us in a
book like Harry Potter the author
discloses much more literally a world
and its logic rules mysteries emotions
and so on this disclosure happens in
dialogue say when Hagrid explains to
Harry that he's a wizard or a wizard
Harry when we flashback to the truth
about Snape or just these simple
descriptions of sentient paintings and
nearly headless ghosts but you say the
same of Star Wars or John wick or any
imaginary world I am your father as
uttered by Darth Vader discloses a whole
new side to the fictional universe of
Star Wars
so narratives disclose their worlds to
us not unlike how the world discloses
itself to us cool but does that mean
there's no difference between learning
that Snape was always on Team Harry and
the notion that Wizards used to poo
themselves are they both just satiating
a curiosity that is fundamental to our
existence
well again I'm going to argue no in fact
the Canon updating via tweets might even
make us all nihilus the problem for
Heidegger is when our understanding of
things becomes instrumental for instance
if I'm looking to make a table a tree
starts looking like nothing but a nice
future to buy for that understanding can
conceal the other facets of its
existence like its importance in the
ecosystem of a forest its history
starting from a seed or even just
appreciating it for its beauty Heidegger
labels this kind of thinking
technological that the vast array of
ways we relate to the world is reduced
to the practical that a tree exists
solely to make would a horse exist
solely to ride or that fellow humans
exist solely as networking opportunities
in the Potter verse the problem isn't
necessarily that were intrigued by
taxonomy of magical creatures but that
we want to reduce a mesmerizing fantasy
into a rational clearly ordered world
what we gain in knowing the history of
plumbing in Hogwarts we lose in our
original relationship to the text our
sense of wonderment inspiration etc for
Heidegger this technological rationality
always concealed
as it reveals in the real world this
leaves us homeless as Heidegger says but
what does he mean by this well that this
narrative we've spun of us looking down
upon our ordered world has made us
forget our original relationship of
being immersed into that world and it
starts to feel alien to us and that's
the kind of nihilism heidegger's talking
about the world loses meaning as
Critchley rides Heidegger insists that
we have to thrust aside our interpretive
tendencies which cover over our everyday
experience of the world and attend much
more closely to that which shows itself
so while we're busy reading JK's updates
about the history of Hogwarts plumbing
we conceal other aspects of the book
like all the fields of Dobby dying of
free elf that and every revelation
usually just forgets more questions and
as a result there's no end to what
Rowling or others must reveal the
revelation that Wizards pooped
themselves until somewhat recently was
begat by a screed in which JK Rowling
felt compelled to explain why there were
bathrooms in Hogwarts Wizards we've been
told don't use muggle technologies so
why do they have plumbing and at this
point instead of letting this fictional
world be she decided to answer that
plumbing was introduced in the 18th
century
so did wizards relieve themselves in
magical bowls or bedpans before then
nope they just let it out wherever they
were before magically disposing of it
from here as I'm sure Heidegger would
have warned if he was caught up on Harry
Potter lore we might ask well then who
installed the plumbing why is there
mention of bedpans in Prisoner of
Azkaban does this imply that wizards can
be too ill to magically in soil
themselves as Madame Pomfrey forgotten
the lost art of deep humand is this the
kind of magic that lies hidden in the
restricted section of the library did
muggle-born wizards back in the day who
were acquainted with an outhouse ever
become homesick for their ancestral way
of doing their business the point is in
our obsession with cannon we can often
lose sight of what makes a piece of
fiction amazing in the first place
Mark Twain recounted in a very
coincidentally high daguerreian way
about a similar experience with his
childhood love of the Mississippi River
as he became an experienced riverboat
pilot the river lost its mystery and
magnificence he wrote in life on the
Mississippi now when I had mastered the
language of this water and had come to
know every trifling feature that
bordered the Great River as from
as I knew the letters of the alphabet I
had made a valuable acquisition but I
had lost something too I had lost
something which could never be restored
to me while I lived all the grace the
beauty the poetry had gone out of the
majestic River for Heidegger there lies
a solution to this called release Minh
that is allowing the world to disclose
itself in all of its facets to us for
Mark Twain that is the poetry and grace
of the Mississippi before he learned to
masterfully navigate its treacherous
waters and maybe that's what letting
Harry Potter be means not learning to
navigate the nooks and crannies of
Cannon to figure out how Draco eats his
steak but just to appreciate it now
importantly that's not to say you can't
engage deeper you can read reread and
constantly discover new facets and
meanings that the text discloses but
that doesn't mean you should necessarily
reread all seven books to simply build
evidence for your theory that Harry owes
back taxes for his inheritance and
that's why for example my favorite show
of all time is Twin Peaks but I refuse
to make a wisecrack video about it
trying to make a logical sense about a
show that is so largely about tone
atmosphere and visual artistry will only
ruin those elements that have captivated
me like no others show so what do you
guys think should we embrace the
scatology of Hogwarts in all its glory
or just let pooping wizards lie let us
know in the comments and as always
thanks for watching guys peace
[Music]